Hi, everyone. I'm
Kendall Clark,
CEO and cofounder at Stardog.
I'm pleased to be talking with
you today at the twenty twenty
knowledge connections
conference.
I've been working in knowledge
graphs and AI since nineteen
ninety nine in a variety of
roles from r and d,
standards work at
the w three c,
to building a knowledge graph
startup at Stardog.
Today, I'm going to be talking
with you about
the disconnected
data world in which
we find ourselves,
how we got here,
and the path that I can see to
get us out of it.
I know you are
all familiar with
the data silo problem,
but I think it's helpful to
reexamine it, break it down to
see how it has
evolved over time
to help us better address it
going forward.
The future we're all driving
towards in the knowledge graph
community is the connected
enterprise,
A way of managing data,
no matter its type or location
or format, to connect it where
it's most useful at
the compute layer,
and to connect it in the way
that's most useful
based on what
it means, not on
its location.
We at Startog are to our core
concerned with this issue of
bringing the differentiated
power of semantic
graph technology
to enterprise data to solve
the data silo problem.
And today, I'm going to share
with you several new features
of the startup
platform that are
taking us to the next step in
connecting data in what is
increasingly
a hybrid and multi
cloud world. Finally,
I'll be leaving about ten or
fifteen minutes for questions
at the end of my talk,
and I'm really looking forward
to hearing those
and and speaking
with you directly.
So before we dive in,
let's take a little
bit talk a little
bit about who we
are at Stardog.
Stardog is
the leading enterprise
knowledge graph platform.
While many graph vendors focus
on graph for better
data storage,
we focus on applying graph for
better data management.
We have customers
all over the world,
but primarily in the e
EU and in the US,
and those clients are focused
in a few select industries,
health care and
life sciences,
financial services,
and manufacturing.
So I'll begin this
talk with a little
history lesson.
Digital transformation,
in addition to
being, of course,
an overused term that makes us
all groan or or
roll our eyes,
has actually become
very relevant,
in this long awful
pandemic year
of twenty twenty.
When I started in
AI and knowledge
graphs, this move to
digital was new,
and it was already
hard enough.
And that was in the purely
relational world,
the world before the web,
before the commercial
Internet,
when the problem was,
mostly just a bunch
of relational
databases that lived in an on
prem data center.
What's happened since then?
In particular, what's happened
to data landscape?
Well, a lot's
happened, of course.
First, the nature
of enterprise
data has changed
dramatically.
Today, we deal with data that
is structured.
Yes, of course,
but also unstructured and semi
structured. The
enterprise data
landscape is highly subject to
change as the rate of data
collection has
accelerated with
the exponential
growth of networks.
First broadband
and now of course
five g. And as businesses have
grown bigger and
become more complex,
and for many of
today's leading
companies, their
core intellectual
property really has
become their data.
What we've been
calling the data
silo problem has
actually gotten
a lot worse.
According to a recent survey,
forty percent of
companies that
consider themselves
data driven
have more than fifty core
disconnected data silos.
The data silos
strictly speaking
are problematic.
Data separated at the storage
layer allows for local control
and governance,
which businesses
of course need.
Often data separation
is is a requirement
of policy and compliance.
However, in our interconnected
complex fast moving world,
maximizing the value of data
requires connecting it.
A business with loads of data
and lots of disconnected data
silos is really no
more intelligent
and therefore no
more adaptable
to change, able
to take advantage
of new market opportunities,
or more responsive to customer
needs than
the purely relational
on prem data center businesses
that ruled the world
just twenty
years ago.
And this is only looking at
the problem purely
from the business
perspective. When
we start looking
at the problem as experienced
by boots on the ground
data people,
the people who need
to operationalize
all this stuff and stitch all
these different
pieces together,
the complexity
of the data data
silo problem just increases.
For better or for worse,
this is the nature
of the beast.
Enterprise data
will either save
us all or well,
it'll save us all,
but only if it doesn't kill us
all first. As
the world develops
new ways to communicate,
businesses will have new types
of data to mine for insight.
But for us data folks,
we'll have a new data problem
to try to connect
into the hole.
And I haven't even
started talking
yet about the data
location issue.
Alright. So that brings
us to the cloud.
let's talk about
the cloud a bit
because it's starting to seem
like people think the cloud
could be magic.
But we data people,
we don't believe in magic.
So the cloud is happening.
It's been happening
for, what,
ten, fifteen years.
How is the cloud's development
impacting the evolution
of the data
management landscape?
We started with
the business and
its on prem data
center full of
relational databases,
and then this data
center started
filling up with
data silos full
of different kinds of data,
data of different types.
Now we add to that a remote
cloud data center.
And, yeah, the same phenomenon
of varying data
types piling up
in different data silos is
happening there too.
While moving data to the cloud
has many benefits,
better connecting your data is
not one of them.
There are many
different flavors
to cloud implementations
as well.
There's, of course,
the public cloud where cloud
resources are accessed
via the public
Internet, and there's
private cloud,
which is dedicated to a single
organization with
the infrastructure
located somewhere.
maybe it's, in fact,
better that we
don't know actually
where, but it's not accessible
to the public Internet.
And there's hybrid cloud,
which is a combination of both
public and private.
Now for software vendors and
business leaders,
the CEO or CFO perhaps,
Hybrid clearly is
the best option.
It offers the ease,
scalability,
and access to the catalog of
apps that is the hallmark of
the public cloud while also
providing the security,
performance,
and cost saving benefits that
characterize
the private cloud.
It even lets
organizations migrate
to the cloud piecemeal.
That's great. In fact,
you've probably
started to notice
in your own organization,
especially if it's
particularly large,
that there has been
a bit of a pendulum
effect lately here with
organizations going all in on
the cloud and now
starting some
of them to swing back towards
the private cloud
and even growing
talk about repatriation or
repatriating some
of their cloud
data assets from public
back to private.
Either way, the cloud is here
to stay no matter
what incarnation
it takes. We all
understand that.
And honestly, all of that is
probably complex enough.
Right? But, alas,
we have one more
turn of the screw
to consider. the place where
the world is headed
isn't the cloud,
one magical place where all
the data is already
connected.
The place we're
headed is hybrid
multi cloud. Now
I just told you
about hybrid,
public and private.
Now let's take take a look at
the final driver
for complexity,
the multi cloud part.
There are now, I
think by my count,
by all claim,
four cloud vendors
that really matter,
at least next year.
Next year, who knows?
Maybe there'll be five.
So we, the data people,
have also got the diversity of
the cloud vendor
offerings to deal with,
a w AWS, of course,
Azure, GCP,
and now Oracle.
In all likelihood,
if you work for
a big organization,
you have a vendor
that your org
picked for public cloud and
maybe a different vendor that
you use for some
legacy assets,
and then perhaps a third that
was brought into the mix when
you acquired a competitor.
Even worse, this multi cloud
phenomenon is not
something that
defines only large
enterprises.
Up to ninety percent
of all businesses,
including small and
medium sized ones,
use more than one cloud.
Or as we should say,
we should really say
us data people.
They have data assets in more
than one cloud.
Just as with
the flexibility and
hybrid cloud considerations,
there are benefits to choosing
multiple cloud providers,
like avoiding vendor lock in,
getting the right
tool for the right
problem, resiliency.
But proliferating disconnected
assets across multi clouds
represents an old
familiar problem,
difficulty
with interoperability
and governance and portability
and management.
And in reality,
all of this cloud
complexity is
making the data silo
problem worse,
not better, which
in turn makes
digital transformation
harder,
not easier.
In the hybrid multi
cloud world,
data is more
physically separated,
making it difficult to unify,
which makes it even
harder to connect.
And of course, public cloud
vendors understand
this very well,
and so they're charging in and
out fees and other,
approaches,
charging you every time you
consolidate data physically.
They certainly want your
organization to
be very happy,
but only within their
walled garden.
And it gets better.
Data is not often
easily extractable
from prepackaged
SaaS applications,
which rarely
provide real access
to the underlining
to the underlying
data storage.
I think by this point,
I've conveyed the extent of
the problem of
disconnected data
and that the slope
of this curve
is really getting worse.
The problem has
only compounded
over the years
as these amazing
new technologies
have made data
people wanna tear
their hair out.
I know I'm preaching
to the choir here,
but it's important
to understand
how we got to this place if
we're going to
figure out the best
way forward.
So let's pause
for a second and
reground ourselves in why we
have all this data
to begin with.
Perhaps that seems
like a silly
thing to do especially
at this event,
but with any problem,
you need to figure
out where you
want to be at
the end if you're
going to make real progress.
So I think we have
data for insight.
We integrate it, mash
it up, model it,
transform it for the purposes
of deriving new knowledge.
Whether our job is to optimize
a business process to increase
profits or to
develop a vaccine
to a deadly pandemic,
Data serves the ends of human
knowledge and know
how or really
what's the point of it.
I'm reminded here
of Metcalfe's law,
the network effect,
that the bigger and
denser a network
becomes, the more
valuable it is.
Now that means there's a kind
of jujitsu move available to
enterprises if
we can help them
pull it off. We can't actually
go from the awful unproductive
data silo problem to a value
creation network inside every
large enterprise,
But that's only going to be
possible if we're
able if you're
able to make these
value creating
connections in the data.
Now clearly,
especially at this
conference, this is
a graph problem.
You all already know this.
Now the great news,
and frankly,
if you're like me,
we all want some
more good news
this year, is that
people outside
of our community are starting
to realize that
this is a graph
problem too. I'll
give you an example.
Back in April, we saw Gartner
publish the headline,
COVID nineteen demands urgent
use of graph data
management and
analytics, and
they've continued
to advocate for
the adoption of
data fabrics of
which knowledge
graphs form a core part.
Now I'm really pleased to see
the increased
adoption of graph
in the market and
the acknowledgment
of of its power
to address some
of the biggest
problems plaguing
data management,
including the data
silo problem.
But a graph database,
no matter what
variety of graph
database, in and
of itself will
not solve the complex problem
I've been describing so far.
We need to go
where the data is
and layer over data graph
capabilities that
can adapt with
the business.
Now as I said at
the beginning,
the future we
envision at StarDog,
and I think I speak in this
sense for the whole
community here,
is the connected enterprise.
And we don't just
talk about it,
but we're helping
our customers
achieve it, through StarDog,
our data platform,
including a third generation
virtualization engine,
an expanding
connector universe,
and the recently
announced StarDog
Cloud. Now I wanna
spend some,
time and the rest of this talk
diving into each one
of these in turn.
Now for us, virtualization has
been key to StarDog's product
vision since our inception.
Data virtualization
as a capability
in the relational data model
world is not new,
but StarDog has been a leader
in graph virtualization.
As I said, we're now building
the third generation virtual
graph engine
inside the StartUp
platform with lots
of innovation
still to come. We call this
capability virtual graphs,
and it's special
made for varied
data with
conflicting definitions
or changing schemas or uneven
properties, just the type of
data you encounter daily in
the enterprise.
Now two features of startup's
virtualization capability in
particular here stand out,
and I wanna share them
with you briefly.
First, Stardog virtual graphs
or are what we call
schema multi tenant,
which means that many schemas
or models can
exist simultaneously
inside of Stardog.
But this as we all know,
there is isn't
ever going to be
one schema for
the whole enterprise.
And all those
schemas and models
can exist at the storage and
compute layers of
the platform.
Second, startup virtual graphs
also offer what
we call virtual
transparency, which
means the platform
is able to answer queries over
all the connected data silos
that feed into the start of
enterprise knowledge
graph without
anyone having to know exactly
where any of the data
really lives.
We call that connecting data
based on what it
means at the compute
layer and not at
the storage layer.
And we think that's key to
thriving in the hybrid multi
cloud world. And
we're not done yet.
We're pushing
the envelope here
with upcoming
platform releases,
and I'm going to dive
into the details
of some of those and and tell
you about them first.
But before I do that,
let me bucket them here to get
us started and
just say they'll
come in about four different,
categories. First,
scalability and performance.
Second, convenience
and usability.
Third, resilience.
Fourth, expressivity
and reach.
So first, let's talk about
scalability and performance.
We started
replatforming StarDog
as a software system of about
a million lines of code from
pure Java to Kubernetes about
two years ago, and the payoff
is really starting
to arrive now.
The scale and
performance of our
virtual graph service
is increasing
dramatically in
Kubernetes with
its elastic scaling ability.
In upcoming releases,
the system will pull data from
data silos to be
stored in local
cache nodes that
are managed by
Kubernetes. This
scalability is
created dynamically,
and it's based on latency and
throughput requirements,
and it's continuously updated
to minimize stale data.
This is leading
us to see about
a five fold speed
up and performance
in virtual graphs in startup.
Not only is is that the result
of of moving to Kubernetes,
but it's also the result of
continuous innovation
in the query
translation and
execution process
internal to the system.
We're starting to see in many
benchmarks virtual
graph performance
matching, the performance of
queries on local data.
We've also improved
handling and
intermediate query
results from
virtual graphs,
and we're storing
those results
in such a way as to minimize
system pauses and avoid out of
memory errors, and the like.
And we've
improved materialization
performance as well.
The now the result of all this
is that when
dealing with large
data sources and
results sets,
these changes
dramatically import
improve performance in real
world use cases.
Now it's also leading to much
better performance
of the virtual
transparency capability I told
you about before to better
optimize virtual queries over
many data sources.
Now second, convenience
and usability,
improvements, especially for
enterprise scale use cases.
Now as many of you know,
when you bring a new capable
capability into the market,
it's typical to focus first on
making it work and making it
work fast and then
making it easy.
We've also been
working hard on
convenience and usability of
StartOgg's graph
virtualization.
I'll mention a few areas of,
improvement briefly.
First, we've made
the virtualization
of StartOgg work better with
the StartOgg cluster for high
availability and scale,
including optimizing how we
handle and distribute
the metadata
about data silos that StarDog
is connecting.
Faster, more
resilient metadata
ingestion means
StarDog users,
get their job done faster.
Second, we've also introduced
finer grained access control
over the virtualized
data sources.
Now the access
control rules for
a data source can be specified
separately from the virtual
graphs created over
those data sources.
That means access
control policies
can be set once perhaps
by IT security,
and then all the rest
of the start
up knowledge graph abides by
those policies.
And that leads
to better access
control sooner.
In fact, most
start up customers
link these policies
to existing
active directory
and LDAP groups
so that the existing role
hierarchy in
the enterprise will
be leveraged and respected
automatically.
Start up connect
silos no matter
where we find them,
including IT security.
Next, we've improved
resilience.
One thing we
quickly learned in
the first generation virtual
graph engine inside of Stardog
is that a database
somewhere in
the enterprise
that's connected
via Stardog may be misbehaving
or poorly connected.
And, yeah, you guessed it,
startup users
blame startup such
as life.
So we've also worked
hard recently
to increase platform
resilience,
especially when handling slow
external data sources.
When a downstream data source
is unusually slow to respond,
that affects query
times and latency,
and in extreme
cases results in
timeouts, which
is a bad customer
experience. Recently,
we've improved how we handle
these cases so as not to waste
cluster resources or to affect
other work occurring
in the start
up cluster. Connections and
queries to external
sources are
now retried automatically to
work around
intermittent issues
and provide a better customer
experience. Finally,
we've improved
the expressivity
and reach of our virtual graph
capability to include text and
geospatial indexing
of data silos.
StartUp now extends text and
geospatial indexing
over virtual
graph data sources.
These indexes are updated
seamlessly and
automatically so
that full text search and
geospatial queries
can be executed
at the compute
layer in StarDog
without requiring modification
of the data in
the storage layer
externally. And
StarDog has also
recently expanded the universe
of sources you can
connect to virtually.
We've provided graph virtual
graph connectors for core
databases for
quite some time.
But now we offer
virtual graphs
capability connectors to about
forty or fifty of
the most common
enterprise applications.
And we think in the connected
enterprise data
sources like HubSpot,
Salesforce, Eloqua,
and SAP matter just
as much as Oracle,
Postgres, and MongoDB.
A big focus for
us going forward
is connecting enterprise data
silos that aren't databases,
but rather they're APIs,
cloud based SaaS
apps, and more.
You can, actually
head over and
see a full list of
this expanded,
virtual graph
connected universe
at start up dot com.
We've made this
investment because
we take our mission
to go wherever
the data is and
connect it quite
seriously. The hybrid multi
cloud world needs
a cost effective
way to connect and query all
the data sources in
the enterprise.
And that means I'm especially
excited to share
this next step
on that journey.
About two weeks ago,
we quietly announced
startup cloud,
the first cloud
native enterprise
knowledge graph platform.
Now not only do we connect all
on prem data, but
we also connect
data in and from
the cloud too.
Again, the real driving force
behind this launch is the need
for end to end connectivity
across the entire enterprise
data ecosystem.
Now that so many organizations
are moving so much
data to the cloud,
to the hybrid multi cloud,
start StartUp is
following them
there to help them
connect those
sources to the ones
they already
have connected on prem.
Startup cloud is
deployed as a managed
service and offers
all the benefits
of all the benefits
that benefits
that you've come
to expect from
cloud based data management,
twenty four seven application
monitoring, service level
guaranteed uptime,
automatic updates,
elastically scalable
infrastructure.
You can deploy it
in your private
cloud or in hybrid cloud
environments and
easily connects
all all on prem and
cloud data sources.
I'm, really super
excited about
this launch of StartUp Cloud.
Like I said, we
released it just
a few weeks ago,
and I can't wait
to see what our
early adopters, friends,
and customers do with
this new service.
Okay.
So I've been talking now for
about twenty minutes,
which means I haven't learned
anything new in at
least twenty minutes.
I'd like to conclude my talk
today first by
thanking you for
attending, your
virtual attendance
and attention to my talk about
In part in part for that
virtualization is
a is a delightful
irony that I'm happy to note.
we have a lot of
exciting stuff
going on at StarDog,
and it's really a pleasure to
share it and really share some
of it first with
you all today.
We think you're the frontline
in this effort to wrangle
enterprise data into
useful control,
and our goal at
Start aug is to
make that job easier for you.
And when your job
is easier and
you can fully
connect data across
types and locations
and vendors,
across all these various data
silos I've talked
about today,
you can deliver
better insights
to your organization.
In the end, that's
what the startup
is really all about.
And I think it's what this
community is
really all about,
actionable knowledge
to make a better
world. This year
of twenty twenty
has fully demonstrated
the importance
of connected data.
The world in which we live is
complicated, intertwined,
rapidly evolving,
and everyone who studies these
trends think
they're just going
to accelerate.
In an interconnected world,
we need connected data.
Well, I think we
here all know,
data is interconnected.
So perhaps more precisely,
I should say,
we need to be
able to see these
interconnections because then
we can predict things
that might happen.
Then we can be
more resilient,
more effective,
and more able to conquer all
the challenges
that lie ahead.
Thank you.
can you elaborate
on Stardog Studio?
sure. Happy to. hi, Olivier.
Startup studio is our,
IDE integrated development
environment for implementing
start up applications.
And so it's,
really a programmer's
tool that
has support for
all of the core
languages that make
up the knowledge
graph stack,
Sparkle, Shackle,
RDF, OWL, our rule syntax,
our mapping syntax,
all of those bits.
it is a web
application available
at start dot studio.
I'm not sure who
was responsible
for that global
top level domain,
but we're we're taking
advantage of it.
and that's available
for use for free.
It's it's part of
our product suite,
but it's, a free tool
for anyone to use.
And it is also on the way to
migrating to become
the beginning
of the user interface
for the start
on cloud product.
And I'll I'll just say briefly
some of the what
we're focusing
heavily on this
tool to move it
from being purely a sort of
software developer ID kind of
platform to being much more
visual with the mutual support
for search and
query as well as
the mapping as well as mapping
and modeling, and that should
be start being available in
January February of
this next year.
Great. another question from
Pallavi Karant.
Yeah. Would like to know if
reasoning on
multishema graphs.
Yeah. Yeah. Thank you.
I can see the question.
good good morning.
Good afternoon,
Pallavi. yeah.
So I talked about
the scheme of
multi tenancy in start,
which is just the idea that
there isn't one
schema in a startup
knowledge graph.
There may be many
and that these
are independent of each other
and in fact they
may be inconsistent
with each other.
They may one schema
may have a definition
of important concept or a rule
that's quite at
odds with that.
A definition of a concept or
rule in another schema,
and that's just perfectly fine
and reasoning.
in start of takes
account of or
uses the definitions in one of
those schemas. So
that's the reason
they're sort of separated
is so that so,
for instance, reasoning and
query answering and machine
learning the other
services that
the platform provides can take
account of the definitions and
the schema information sort of
separately at the same time.
So yeah,
reasoning does work or is
integrated with
the schema multi
tenancy.
Great. Mark from Mark.
Does the SAP
connector all support
support document
retrieval like
fetching an invoice
and PDF format?
Yeah. Thank you. Hi mark.
the sap connector as presently
constituted searches the what
we call maybe the metadata of
the of the back end.
It is not yet able
to do document
retrieval, although that's
something we've
been taking a look
at as you may or
may not know,
StarDog includes
a subsystem we
call bites which
is the NLP and
document storage
layer of the system,
which allows us to
store documents
index index them
for later query
within the system.
those documents can be stored
in HDFS and s three and a few
other places. And,
one of the things
we're looking
at in the future is being able
to pull documents out of SAP
into the local
Stardock store.
not not that's not working,
or we haven't added
that capability
just yet.
Great. Another one
from Olivier.
With regard to tech search,
do you rely upon
the underlying
tech search
facilities or do you
have your own index in stack?
hello again, Olivier.
if a combination
of those two are,
the the search capabilities
inside of Startog are based on
a at this point pretty heavily
modified version of lucine.
So we we we use
lucine and then
we have built up over the last
few years of I
wouldn't say a fork,
but a a heavily
customized leucine
layer and that provides the,
the smart the the search
capabilities.
we're we're also
we we have a road
map item for second half of
twenty twenty one to move more
in an elastic search,
sort of
distributed architecture
for that.
But presently,
it's a it's a kind
of modified version
of BlueCeam.
Great. And from Veronica,
thank you for great talk.
You mentioned scalability.
What are the limitations of
Stardock around scalability?
good question. Hi, Veronica.
Well, it's it's
a bit dependent
on what features
of the system.
You mean
the the machine learning
and the text search
and the query
answering all scales sort of
differently, but let's just
restrict ourselves to query
answering one of the things I
wanted to do and
we'll talk and
and we've we've a bit run out
of time is we'll be releasing
some benchmarking in the in
the new year. I
wanted to announce
that here I'll
I'll just softly
mention it in the Q and a.
We have been testing
single node,
StarDog query,
Sparkle query answering
to the hundred
and fifty billion
triple layer,
level recently,
which is a a a a pretty big
expansion of of where
we are presently.
So I expect you
all to see that
available, and we do monthly
releases sometime in the first
quarter of this next year.
And then as I said,
there's lots of other aspects
of scalability.
Happy to answer
a a follow-up.
Grace.
Jean from Jean,
what is the best
way to integrate
data using virtualization like
Denodo or by exposing data in
open data format like RDF?
In the latter case,
it imposes to set up sparkle
access point for
each data source.
Correct? Question mark. yes.
that's one way to
do it in the latter
case in your in your
a b disjunct there.
there's, you know,
alternative in
the b case where
start out also
includes a native
ETL capability that's actually
powered by the same
mappings and
modeling that powers our
virtualization capability.
So you can always
ETL data into
the platform if that's what's
sort of required operationally
but I think the other thing I
wanna say is
our virtualization
capability and
the way it the way
it works is it it treats other
data sources as
if they were in
this open data
format like RDF,
and that and
that's what I mean
by talking about
connecting data
at the compute
layer rather than
at the storage layer.
So, Denodo, which is a a very
fine relational
probably the leading
relational
virtualization platform
does all of this at
the storage layer,
in terms of of
SQL as they have
a different model.
And and and that
means that SQL
or relational
based virtualization
inherits the limitations of
the relational data model.
So when I said in my talk that
connecting data in the widest
scale of the enterprise
is a graph
problem, it's really a graph
data model problem,
which is really say
it's not a relational
data model problem.
so in some sense,
that distinction,
you know, using virtualization
or using an open data
format like RDF,
what startup is
doing is making
those really to be
the same thing.
Thanks, Kendall.
also from Veronica,
second question.
You mentioned
Shackle support.
Do you full shackle
supports as
described in the w three c
recommendation?
yes. We do. I I
there may be a few
tiny bit of pieces,
in core cases of the spec that
we don't support,
but it is substantially
full support.
I can't help but
point out that
star dog integrity constraint
validation system,
which shipped for
the first time
in twenty eleven,
I believe predated the shackle
standards work by
many years and
after supporting
in the marketplace
commercially start
off integrity
constraint validation,
which used Allison tax rather
than RDF and taxes
and shackle.
We recently
announced deprecation
of ICB and we're
sort of all in
on shackle because the market
has spoken and
the market wants
to use shackle and
and that's fine.
So we're really
proud of the work
we did to pioneer
data validation
in the RF world and again,
II think there
may be a few very
tiny cases as you
probably know
Veronica specifications can be
quite complex
things with often
times requirements
or capabilities
that are that are
that have a sort
of smaller commercial impact.
So I believe our
shackle support
is substantially complete.
Thanks Kendall.
so, Ellie, question.
What kinds of
applications would
the start up team be
delighted to see?
Oh, well, I mean,
strictly speaking,
very big ones that are in
production and
and strategically
essential to large
enterprises.
That's our that's our thing.
I can say a little bit
less facetiously.
I think Applications
so II think
our first start on
cloud customer,
which I'm not
quite ready to be
able to talk about
will will be
pulling together over several
different cloud and on prem
environments, one of the IT
world's largest supply chains
with respect to resellers
customers product information
support so that
they're thinking
about this as
their product and
channel graph,
product and channel
knowledge graph.
And this is a real
a very large,
technology company, you know,
a real stalwart of
the of the Fortune
five hundred.
And it'll be
a great example of
this thesis that we have that
the hybrid multi
cloud development
is really making
the data problem
harder, which means we need to
be more thoughtful
and intentional
about data management systems
that address that kind of
complexity and diversity.
So, any new customers
are great,
but I suspect we would be
especially happy to see ones
that are using our
capabilities to,
connect data across
hybrid multi
cloud data assets.
Great. And then one minute,
one more question.
and I do yeah.
We'll reiterate the Slack.
Will will continue
after this.
From Jean, for good
data governance,
is it advisable that very IT
every IT project
provides an application
data model?
UML is better than nothing,
but not inter interpretable by
a machine. Is it realistic to
request an owl instead,
which requires new
competencies,
which are not well
known presently?
well, I for Jean,
I appreciate the very simple
question here at the end.
that that one's a doozy.
let me just try
to take a crack
at it by saying that
there's a couple
options. I don't
know that an owl
model for every
application is required,
certainly not
a deno like a new
owl model Often
what's required
is the subset of
the applications
data model that
should be exposed
publicly, can be
exposed publicly
with lightweight RDF schema or
with a little bit of hour or
with no hours. So that's often
sufficient. I'll
also point out
that there is a lot
of work, I think,
supported by the o
g and a variety
of vendors who were probably
part of this community or at
this conference
to make a subset
of UML semantics
in UML diagrams
machine interpreter will by
giving
an algorithmic translation
to owl to subsets of owl.
So all is not
lost with respect
to Uml and machine
interpretability.
That's that's you
know only for
some a subclass of of
all uml diagrams.
So I don't think
for instance,
the sequence and interaction
diagrams count there,
but the sort of
uml diagram you
use for a data model,
may well be
interpretable by my
machine by being
translated to a so,
I'd encourage you to look into
that if if you have it.